uh from the post millennial Trump
nominated for Nobel Peace Prize by GOP
rep for historic Abraham Accords it's
not the first time Trump has been
nominated for the prestigious award and
I do want to say as we we we get going
it doesn't mean all that much it's a
nice thing someone can say but I do
think it matters because Donald Trump no
new Wars Donald Trump setting timelines
for bring our troops out of these
countries trying to get our troops out
of Syria negotiating with some of the
worst people in the world and of course
the Abraham Accords if anyone deserves
this it's him however Barack Obama did
end up winning one a long time ago
despite doing nothing the story is on
Tuesday rep Claudia Tenny announced that
she had nominated Donald Trump for a
Nobel Peace Prize citing his
groundbreaking efforts to Foster peace
and cooperation between Israel Bahrain
Morocco Sudan and the United Arab
Emirates via the highly praised Abraham
Accords Tenny compared the former
president's work to that of the 1978
peace agreement between Israel and Saudi
Arabia the 1994 Oslo Accords both of
which were recognized and reward awarded
by the Nobel Peace Prize committee
Donald Trump was instrumental in
facilitating the First new peace
agreements in the Middle East in almost
30 years for decades bureaucrats foreign
policy professionals and international
organizations insisted that additional
Middle East peace agreements were
impossible without a resolution to the
Israeli Palestinian conflict president
Trump proved that to be false and she
goes on to praise uh uh the former
president and the work that he did and
it's kind of sad I got to tell you right
now we are looking at Joe Biden who has
announced his decision that he has a
decision not that he's we don't know
exactly what he's going to do but the
speculation is that he will strike the
Iranian Navy directly which would
essentially be a unilateral declaration
of war and could trigger Iran to
officially and formally declare war and
Congress would not have declared that so
that's a disaster but it's also sad when
you realize Donald Trump was President
we had no new Wars he leaves
everything's falling apart the Abraham
Accords are basically gone Israel Gaza
all that conflict Ukraine China has
deployed warships surrounding Taiwan
Venezuela is going to make a move on
Guyana World War III may be on the
horizon houthi Rebels are shutting down
one of the most prominent shipping lanes
in the world to the Red Sea and none of
this is happening when Trump's president
maybe because why Trump threatened to
Nuke people is that it well you've also
got ecoas popping off there in West
Africa as well you've got ecoas and the
ecoas alliance with Nigeria and those
other countries uh they were threatening
with uh uh what is it Burkina Faso Mali
and I can't remember the Third Country
there oh wow that could pop off as well
well I realize it was that bad lost all
hope it's everywhere well hopefully you
know this is the fourth time's the charm
Trump finally gets Nobel Peace Prize I
mean way back in the day Australia like
a coalition of Australian um officials
nominated him because they said under
the Trump Doctrine he's pulled americ at
endless Wars and that's been good for
the entire world and now we have Joe
Biden who's like but I like for I think
this might be fun um the other thing is
that the Nobel Peace Prize decision
comes out in October which would be the
most hilarious October Twist of all time
that they actually are like you know
we're really scared of World War III so
we're going to give it to Trump and the
elections three weeks later what but
what are the odds like close to zero
that they actually give it to him I
wonder if you can actually ruining my
dreams negative I wonder if you can
actually make bets on that cuz
apparently everyone's going to get mad
at me for bringing this up but you can
make bets on whether or not Travis will
propose to Taylor Swift like they're
actually offering that on Sports books
or something like this so anyway we will
not we will not we will not get into
that subject we'll go back to talking
about war and conflict and the uh the
Peace Prize good look I'm I'm sorry I
got to tell you guys the it's all fake
everything's fake the world's fake I
just I just don't believe anything's
real anymore everything's conspiracy
like Truman Show fake or what kind of
fake you talking because brck Obama won
the Nobel Peace Prize and he did nothing
like come on I don't believe it's a real
thing well he did he he became president
while being you know of
color it's pretty
big brought peace to the world and
everyone sang Kumbaya and uh there were
love beads in meditation you remember
how great those years were you know I he
did you know this actually this is
actually funny he's the um how do I say
this he is the um he holds the record
for most children killed by a Nobel
Peace Prize winner what an honor what a
distinguish
I don't know that that is actually true
but it's a meme it's like Barack Obama
holds the most the record for most
children killed by Nobel Peace Prize
winner and uh I think that's probably
true because like I don't know I have to
pull up a list of all the other Nobel
Prize winners but uh he he blew up a lot
of them you know that was that was his
thing he was unless unless Stalin won a
Nobel Peace Prize or something right
that's true I mean Hitler was on the
cover of Time Magazine he was person of
the year you know and then well so is
Obama what are you suggesting one
substantially worse than the other but
Obama was pretty bad yeah I don't know
man and then the dude that he uh that uh
he mentored Joe he's uh somehow managed
to do even worse I have I have to
imagine we we we've been speculating
this since Joe Biden got the presidency
I don't want to say got elected got the
presidency uh that he's basically just
like this ragd doll they threw in the
room so that they can do all of the bad
things they want to do and then make him
the Pariah basically so they're thinking
like okay we need to go War here here
here here and here whoever we put in and
whoever does this it's going to destroy
them ah Joe Biden he's he's basically
dead anyway right he's got like he's
past the average life expectancy of the
US male he's got plates in his brain
what does he care we'll tell him we'll
pardon his son or something they did
just assume he'd be in incredibly
submissive right they did just say he'll
he'll listen to us and he'll follow what
we want which I think is sort of the
problem right now I think they actually
did want him to be a one-term president
and he is kicking and screaming he and
Jill do not want to leave the White
House I don't know I can't believe that
I think it's kind of like his ego rubs
UPS against their agenda like they want
him gone they want to do their own like
neocon neolib thing but he's still like
that you know long ago he was a fiery
dude if you look at him when he was in
the Senate he was rather forceful he's
got a big ego he talks about wrapping a
chain around corn Pop's head and weird
stuff like that I was a bad dude back in
the 19 60s let no no he said Corn Pop
was the bad dude but I got to be honest
when I hear that story about how you
know Corn Pop was threatening him I'm
willing to like you he he Joe Biden said
I'm sitting in the pool and the kids are
rubbing my legs and got hairy legs and
I'm just like corn poop probably saw Joe
Biden doing some weird stuff with kids
and was like yo we're gonna stop you and
that's when Joe pulled out a chain and
like banged it on the ground right but
rain barrel got it Rusty that's right be
interesting to see like what so many
details from corn poop's point of view
what happened yeah why can we never find
corn poop that's the big question is it
would be very very politician of him to
take this story where potentially
someone was like hey leave those kids
alone and he's like and it turns out I
scared that that guy off look it was
Works in my favor like or or it turns
out that corn poop is black and got
racially profiled no he was no I'm
pretty sure corn poop's black dude oh
God yeah yeah yeah that's that that was
that's not even a surprise yeah and then
someone made an animation of how he was
talking about the kids rub his legs like
dude the guy he you know his story is
that corn poop wasn't wearing what his
his his bathing cap or something like
that something like that he called yeah
I called him I know I thought he he
dived off the board the wrong way if I
remember correctly or he was running or
something yeah I don't know I think all
I know is his story is total BS like the
reality is is probably there is no corn
poop in I didn't think there was but I
almost wish it was real me too because
that would be just the best thing ever
if it was if if cornpop was a real dude
I'd imagine he was like a good guy guy
who was like watching Joe Biden creep on
kids right and he was a leader of a
bunch of he ran a bunch of bad dudes and
and his daughter was at the pool that
day Bad Dudes saw churchgoing young men
who didn't like watching Joe Biden like
grope little girls or something is that
is that like why is this Sky lifeguard
he shouldn't be here yeah one have gone
I mean but to your point I don't know if
this has to do with war or anything but
you know I was going to say funny anyway
yeah I I think it's good to speculate
about to question Joe Biden who who gets
caught in all kinds of lies all the time
but your point video of him exists where
he is sort of speaking forcefully he was
influential he did have a career in
politics for some time and I think that
underscores sort of how serious his
decline is I mean he's the oldest
president in the country's history he
wants to be the second he wants to
defeat himself for that title uh but
Trump isn't young Trump is Trump is in
his like what late mid mid
778 yeah so he's late 70s he's way more
cognitively together than Biden is there
are ton I mean even like Chuck Grassley
in Iowa he is in his 80s and he is more
together than than Biden is right now
the fact that Biden is actively slurring
and it's not even a question of just
like we don't like this guy he is
declining so rapidly it's undeniable I
think that's one of the reasons why the
uh Democrats have turned against him we
have all kinds of Democrats who say he's
too old to be there and at least on
paper he has access to the nuclear codes
which really should terrify people I
know he he obviously has handlers behind
the scenes that do most of the stuff for
him like a lot of the decisions that
makes aren't yeah exactly I mean which
one is worse the person in charge of the
nuclear Arsenal and everything else that
goes on at the executive capacity is
completely out to lunch or a bunch of
other people that aren't out to lunch
and clearly are malevolent they're the
ones in charge and he's just a
figurehead I don't know which one is
scarier I think it's actually a little
bit of both all right I agree and here's
how I see it Joe Biden's in charge but
incoherent yeah and so people are just
like you know we're all sitting at this
big table it's funny because people
can't see it whenever they come here
they're like this room is so big it's
like yeah it's like 15 by 35 or whatever
but the table's massive so you got all
these people sitting around the
situation room and you know a missile
just struck a US military base in Iraq
and then the president is briefed and
he's sitting there and he's got this
look on his face or he's wearing
aviators and eating ice cream because
you know it helps people with
Alzheimer's and then uh they're like Mr
President what are we doing he was like
come on man you know got a g b get go
and they're like oh and they look at
each other like uh yeah whatever you say
Mr President then he leaves and they're
like what what do we do I don't know
what he said like what are we supposed
to do don't worry he'll forget by
tomorrow whatever he was trying to say
so just just do something and I I really
do think this because when you look at
Afghanistan it doesn't even look like a
coherent plan to fail on purpose like
abandoning bam Air Force Base in the
middle of the night and and letting
random people rans sack it I'm like
there are better ways to pull out of
Afghanistan in a way that props up your
enemies
and there are better ways to pull out
Afghanistan correctly and nothing was
executed properly and the stories we
learned about the the uh uh the
withdrawal from Afghanistan was that all
of these different military leaders were
just like frantically confused and
didn't know what was going on and this
is how you end up with like you had um
Afghani Security Forces flying
helicopters just land them and get out
and run run run in a random Direction
because there was no Logistics once the
Air Force Base shut down and the US just
stopped these guys are like hello hello
like what's happening like we're cut off
and they're like I'm out of here dude
cuz you're you're no longer working for
any cohesive unit seems to me more like
Joe Biden says true and not a sh of
pressure and then everyone's just like I
have no idea what to do and so they just
do whatever it's totally just without
coordination yeah I I think it is a mix
of the two it was funny because Biden
did have the coherence to call the then
president of Afghanistan before
everything happened and say oh just lie
to people and tell them that it's okay
because we need time to coordinate the
withdrawal that he pushed back
unilaterally but then they didn't
actually withdraw any of the materials
right the the man is clearly sick uh
anyone even the Liberals I think know it
it's just that they don't want to admit
to the fact that Joe Biden quite clearly
has difficulty so they cope with it by
pointing out some verbal flaw that
Donald Trump had you know a week ago
yeah exactly they point out some flaw in
his wording so he used the wrong word he
referred to Nikki Haley as Nancy Pelosi
which I think was kind of on the nose
basically exactly yeah basically are the
same ideologically uh in order to cope
with it thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8:00 pm and become a member over at
timcast.net